enjoy the show on this episode of dudy
trans witches for abortion will you
marry me
[Music]
no
y everything you're thinking will be the
things I
say I made the world inside your head
cheers to
be all you got to do cheers into the
drink Che yeah cheers uh we still
haven't figured out what's in that hole
one of these days hey welcome to dudy
welcome all it's a dudy full day the day
after Canadian Thanksgiving I'm Will
Sasso I'm Chad couchin and this is of
course dudy the only podcast in the
history of our uh short species time
span on this planet that is controlled
by and run by and created by an
artificial intelligence that has access
to all of Will and I's person personal
data all of our uh email messages text
messages everything we've watched bought
eaten listened to and it uses all that
data to tailor the show to our comedic
sensibilities and it's also given me
this what's that the episode
championship belt which I have now
retained
for so many I've lost 27 something
episodes and it's a good thing that's a
good thing that Chad has the belt and
it's a good thing that dudy does what
dudy does d are good pal
hey it's got all our search histories
and purchase history all the [__] that
Chad talks about and uh and that's good
but it's also good that uh I'm not just
saying this because I'm trying to Curry
favor with d okay oh it's also good that
we are two dudes [__] around which
is what I say about every single podcast
hey you know what we're just having a
good time not to discredit D and what D
does because it's very very important
and again I'm not just saying that for
some for some extra stroke that's not
that's not why I do this link tree.com
dudy has all the links you need to
follow and interact with the show across
all spaces and platforms please make
sure that you are subscribed to our
YouTube channel and across every podcast
platform whatever you use to listen to
podcast and give us a thumbs up give us
a thumbs up okay and if you give this
episode a thumbs up that's a good thing
that I've also said and if D's paying
attention which I know D is then that
way hold on dude then that hold on
brother hold on D not to wo you right
away dude but when you oh no dude oh and
I raise him up from the dead
oh and he's up um om
om
sh well that's not dudy dude that's
Indiana Jones and Temple d That's Temple
Doom dude when he RI that hard out of
that guy's chest bro dud that gave me
nightmares as a child dude yeah dude and
that's just barely Hulk Hogan that's
just that's just the minimum amount dude
that's when you put a Hulk Hogan
impression into a pan dude and you just
simmer it down dude you get that
reduction you got to scrape it off the
bottom brother that's what Chad's
impersonations are dude ruction dude
yeah dude you reduces the reduces them
dude absolutely nothing anyway uh you
know points and [__] right it doesn't
matter what matters is we're having a
good time on the show and if you give
this episode a thumbs
up with us as always is
lul the Italiano that's the Italian
Street dog and he's so sweet oh man I
gave him a haircut I know he's so cute
with the haircut sweee boy ears little
bunky
boy oh I love him he's just follow me
around everywhere hey Lulu you got a
haircut and even a t on your cut on your
tail yeah you got a cut my hair and make
me look good I don't even have to go do
the barber hey that's right so lulia
what are you what are you what are you
going to make uh what are you going to
make for dinner night I no much just the
pasta you
know you like pasta with oil and garlic
yeah yeah how do you how do you do is
what you do you put the garlic in the
pan with olive oil and then the red
chili flake and make a make sure that
you got some parsley standby H boil up a
nice spaghetti Linguini and then you
want a long pasta for that it's good
that way and then we save some pasta
water and then you put also a salt in
the pan with the oil a nice more oil
than usual and the garlic make sure it's
a nice Brown and then you put in the
pasta very alente and then add little
water you know Mish mix it around and
then then you eat oh oh give me a kiss
oh oh that was good good
stuff one I'm okay not
yet I love him he's taking those from oh
he's a sweet boy he's a sweet
boy welcome to the 77th power drenched
episode of dudy call me dudy are you
ready to feel the steal and close the
deal live the dream and drink the cream
pick the pear and pull the hair oh wait
neither of you have hair therefore you
have both been dude
Zed oh sure okay got us zing zing before
we start today's astonishing show I want
to play you a voicemail I got over the
weekend for context this was sent to me
2 hours after Grier penley and susten
Test's dudy season 2 article came out in
the Atlantic you know the one I'm
talking about it was called dudy season
2 is more important than food great
article by the way okay I'm just going
to play this voicemail now here we go
hey it's it's fencil I read the penley
Thomas piece it was [__] as usual
anytime those two clowns partner up all
you get is them stroking each other's
massive egos with $10 words and
pointless Meandering about Sonic Tableau
whatever the [__] that is penley spent
his whole career trying to prove to his
Junior High basketball coach that he
should have made the team and Tom must
will take any opportunity she can to
plug her Wikipedia page they're hacks
you want a real review here I'll give
you one dudy sees to is oh [__] that's
my ex-wife on the other line got to take
it I forgot to pick up our kid from
athletes I'll call you back later okay
so Brad fencil is that's George Lucas it
sounds exactly like George Lucas it
could be Brad fenel at the rich world of
these podcast reviewers is really
starting to get built out now so Brad
spencil has a ex-wife and a kid who's in
athletes yeah Brad spencil hates the
other uh podcast critics yeah we've
learned that much I don't know I don't
know I still don't know how he got my
number now let's get into the show today
I'm hitting you with four Savory
segments designed to give you both
opportunities to prove to me who should
win the episode Championship you're
getting Alex Jones in the year 2063
Taylor swiftest the will sash show and a
standard psychological evaluation then
you're getting a brand new episode of
dudy after dudy on dudy Plus at
patreon.com dudy where I'll name this
week's episode
champ unreal okay four segments couple
of them we've heard uh before we've done
we got the Alex Jones coming I mean he's
just giving you layups here in my
opinion what are you trying to say
you're getting an Alex Jones I I feel
like you're Alex Jones you're Ventura
your Hogan all your impressions
basically when you have one of those
segments it's like he's just giving it
to you he's saying here you go all you
got to do is do this well and and then
and so you're saying this because you
and dudy got something going and you got
that belt around your waist and then
then what and then I and if I don't win
at the end of the show you you can't me
you can't making excuses you [__] you
[__] layup I'm just saying [__]
just handed it to you under ho dude up
whatever man uh I'm excited about this
uh episode we got standard psychological
evaluation at the end we did that before
that was very interesting hey hey I know
you are uh really digging uh what's
happening in Bachelor land myself and my
wonderful wife Molly watched t two weeks
in a row now I I think we're in the
golden Bachelor yeah what say you I'll
give you an impersonation and I'll I'll
tell it to you in my impersonation this
is Gary Turner the golden Bachelor you
this is actually a I think having a lot
of fun here and I think my wife is in
this room at 72 years old I got to tell
you I didn't think it was going to be
possible to find a love like my exwife
Tony but it's what she want for me now I
going to find it here on Golden Bachelor
it's so good the golden Bachelor is the
best product The Bachelor has ever made
ever ever in its 2 Rich 22 year history
really yeah okay good I'm glad I'm I'm
glad I'm on board because it's it seems
like it's perfect for television it's
per perfect for broadcast television as
the demographic gets a little bit older
it's uh you know it's a perfect uh yeah
it's a perfect perfect uh Avenue for you
know hey [__] [__] I enjoy the [__]
show too you know what I mean I got home
from work I [__] get a load on you
know I get a few silver bullets and I
[__] drunk them down and then you
know me and my wife Marie we watch the
[__] golden Bachelor and I like I
said before [__] you know I'm not trying
to be W or crash or rude but they there
more than a few [__] mature Brads on
that show wouldn't mind right bending
over the [__] hood of my the 1982
Dodge Shelby that I just [__] uh you
know I [__] put that [__] together
restored that one I mean that's one of
the big uh things that people are
talking about for this season what are
the fantasy suites going to be like
which is the overnight dates if you
don't watch The Bachelor it's when the
cameras leave supposedly and the uh lead
and the players get to engage in sex or
have political conversations or
conversations about religion well you
got to be careful because it's on
broadcast television you can't get uh
you can't get rated R speaking of rated
R dude the Rated R Superstar Edge Adam
Copeland is now in aew and I know you
don't know what that no don't be like
you know what that means you don't know
you don't know what the [__] that means
oh I kind of do though so did you did
you watch that did you see Edge go to
aew yeah dude yeah yeah okay now and
Edge you know that edge sort of reunited
with his old pal Christian Jay Rizo
exactly
and okay so what if okay what' you think
of it well look here's what happens
every once in a while in a a wrestler's
career no oh yeah every once in a while
wrestler's career they they hit a real
height in WWE biggest show in the world
right yeah and then they fade a little
bit their importance in the storylines
that are happening in the WWE it kind of
lessens and it's like how do you
reinvigorate that now you go to aew this
is basically what Edge did Edge has made
himself arguably in my opinion more
important now than he ever was in
WWE people are going to be looking at
this move as like oh [__] Are other
people going to start doing this too
okay couple of things number one it re
it enrages me that when you do that and
you having not seen any of this [__] and
you sort of know what you're talking you
don't know what you're talking about but
it sounds
like uh but you know what while you
can't eclipse the incredible career of
of edge yeah what you just said is kind
of reflective of what Paul LC Triple H
said the COO of uh WWE say Hey you know
uh we we parted we parted ways Edge has
done everything that he can do here yeah
and this is an amicable split and it's
not a future he's not being future
endeavored when Vince goes uh good luck
with your future
Endeavor you're fine no it's more uh
it's more amicable anyway it was great
when uh Christian told Edge to go [__]
himself yeah I agree you guys both know
that Alex Jones recently opened a Schism
in the fabric of time and wound up in
the year
2063 he spent 12 months there and has
come back with notes about the
astonishing things he
witnessed will you know what I want to
hear give me some of your sweet Alex
Jones don't hold back and don't skimp on
me give me everything you've got I can
take it and don't forget to put that
astonishing little Wiglet on top of your
head this is Alex Jones in the year 2063
begin do you have your Wiglet I do have
my Wiglet
actually um okay so Alex Jones 2063 hold
on I the last time we did this was one
of the funniest [__] things of all
time
oh all right hydrated Chad that's gross
um yeah it was a lot of fun I I like
doing the Alex Jones thing and I keep
since the last time I kept the Wiglet oh
nice the Wiglet is here in my French fry
hat so um hat in a hat yep hat in a hat
on a hat all right uh this is in the
dudy folder hold on there it is okay all
right there's a lot of prep for this one
we got a wig but dudy gets what dudy
wants you know what I mean and I'm not
just I'm not faking the funk on that
Chad I really do want dudy to enjoy the
show along with everybody else this is
good wig this is good wig play you got
to first you got to put it on but then
you you you you got to put it back where
although he's he's just bald now but it
looks more like it's like kind of
classic Alex Jones can I use that term
is that a is that a term we would
totally okay all right this for those of
you listening on on uh podcast I'm
putting on a [__] wig the Wiglet
really makes it I mean you you look a
lot like him with the Wiglet yeah you
get that
it helps me get into it I got up in the
middle of the night to get a glass of
orange juice and when I opened the
fridge a Schism pulled me through time
and and and and and and and and I I
wound up living for 12
months in the year 2063 I took as many
notes as I could Chad good to see you
again good to see you too Alex how are
you doing pretty good I'm glad you took
notes I we all want to know what
happened we all want to know what
happened
2063 when I went 40 years from now okay
number one squares are circles now oh
yeah that
seems that seems odd it it turns out
China bought geometry and they changed
all the shapes oh and triangles are
rect rectangles now and uh trapezoids
are doer
Cadron and heptagons are nonagons and
hey Chad you'll find this interesting uh
myriagon are now hexadecagon oh yeah I
do that's pretty interesting oh those
are changes a lot for me and and the
Pentagon is a pile of rubble oh [__] I
don't know when it happened okay yeah
well you know and you know what that's
all about Chad if you control uh uh if
you can control numbers yeah then uh you
can control shapes and there's all sorts
of things yeah with you know yeah and
hey you uh they went in uh Co 19 when
they did Co 19 in Wuhan you know why
they were essentially trying to uh make
the virus in the Wuhan lab to study it
you know what they were originally
trying to do no they were trying to come
up with a another a salt additive a food
additive like like MSG uh that could uh
know that yeah a better flavor enhancer
than do it for Chinese food do you like
Chinese food yeah what's your favorite
Chinese food uh probably like vegetable
chag [__] I like I like Duck I love
duck I love love
meat get some whiskey and some Chinese
got some good they got some good whiskey
you laugh but all right no don't watch
it all right number two yeah uh uh
Target is a gay satanic church
now what that's a big change that's what
it says right here they used to be a
store that's store but now in 20063
based on the massive success of their uh
clothing lines featuring satanic
representations and Impressions they
follow the money and change their
business model turning uh the the former
retail giant into the largest and most
successful uh satanic Church on the
globe oh wow and uh often Dawning a
blood red top
hat
but high priest Timothy shalam oh no
broadcasts his weekly satanic Target
sermons directly into the chipped brains
of members of the target death Circle
Rewards
program shalam is gearing up for a 20
2066 uh presidential run under under the
campaign slogan Target is coming for
your children all right that seems like
an interesting uh would you vote for him
Chad probably sh me yeah yeah you shop
at at Target uh no I don't really but
yeah you'd like some you wear t-shirts
yeah right you should probably get get
get your hands on one of those t-shirts
that they got uh now Target says uh
trans witches for abortion would you
like to wear You' probably wear a
t-shirt that says that I would yeah you
get them in black and match your black
pants and your black shoes and your
black
soul this isn't performative
coughing number three
uh and
ah sometimes it helps me do Alex Jones
when I sure I sound more like how's this
wig doing it looks great dude you you
really do look like him I mean
MH Toyota's run on Pig
seaming what gas prices are so high the
people stop buying cars and TOA Toyota
invented an engine that that doesn't
need gas it can run on Pig seaming so
people have pigs as pets and hey this is
true and the pigs have to [__] their
cars every morning uh before work it
doesn't work doesn't work with human
seen uh I tried it I I [__] a tundra
and it wouldn't start oh God
what
okay sure what's your king Chad what are
you into sexually you want to tell me
about hey you should go uh you want to
go up to Bohemian Grove yes I actually
do well I would I took a a hidden camera
in there went in there because I used to
I used to sneak into military bases and
stuff and boheman Grove was started by
uh Mark Twain I know as a yeah as just a
way to I think they were just there to
plow prostitutes and stuff and then the
Bilderberg Group got into it and black
rock and all those guys and then they
then then then then then then then then
just world leaders dressed up in in
dresses and stuff and I went up there uh
undercover and I think you I think you'd
really I think you'd really I think
you'd really like it I'm very curious
about Bohemian Grove I know that it is
real I know the video you're talking
about and uh I do think that world
leaders go there to do what I don't know
weird rituals and [__] I guess you want
to [__] me no I'm good I'm joking thank
you I'm glad you want to though no I
don't all
right number four Nancy Pelosi's ghost
is is haunting the New York Stock
Exchange she died in in in in in 2043 at
108 years of age her her last words were
oh one more trade that's what you wanted
to do two weeks later people saw her
ghost trying to uh short 60,000 shares
of Apple oh wow and hey hey
ah ghost start supposed to make trades
so they didn't let her and and that
trade would have made $1.2 billion
that's a lot of money by shorting Apple
something like that right here she
started Financial advice YouTube channel
called inside information with Nancy
Pelosi's
ghost I've been following her picks and
and let's just say that the ghost don't
miss I love money I love money you love
money Chad I don't seriously let's [__]
on you want to [__] on a pile of money
no dude I'm good no I'm joking I'm
joking hey you know where we could get
some good Chinese food is um uh San
Francisco you ever go to San Francisco
for Chinese
food I've actually never even been to
San Francisco oh yeah it's great you
know we uh what we should do if you and
I uh if we hang out we could go to uh we
could go to uh Charlie Sheen's house in
Malibu okay and and stay the night and
uh get you know get a load on and party
and then we could just borrow one of
Charlie's cars you like a Porsche Lambo
yeah Lamborghini will drive up Bohemian
Grove and it's beautiful it's between
there's the russom river and uh there's
a mountains there and it's in a Gorge
yeah I think you'd I think you'd really
uh for privacy I think you'd really
enjoy it I'll go college kids are baking
their
genitalia it's a new Tik Tock Trend
exposing your genitals to high levels of
solar radiation on low days to give it a
pink uh glow for 8 hours okay got to
admit it does look cool I did my balls
and taint and and then I did my butthole
too one
not
what you know the CIA is in contact with
big uh movie producers and movie stars
and stuff like that they like that's
true that is true the
um Chris Carter guy who did um X Files
yeah yeah he's a good he's a good
personal friend and yeah so they hit him
up and they go and the CIA especially
you know they they write these scripts
you write scripts yeah so have you ever
been approached by the CIA or anything
like that no I the stuff I write isn't
really uh in that world I think so they
don't they don't [__] with me too
much they
[Laughter]
don't and then they because it's it
works on a subconscious level yeah you
got first you got the conscious you got
the unconscious and then you got the
subconscious okay and and and and and
and if Chris Carter writes something in
a in the show in the lone Gman about a a
Boeing 747 hitting a high-rise Tower or
uh or an organized u u u
uh pandemic yes then they then that come
for you yeah and then that that they
yeah
he
okay Jesus Christ all right number six
uh women
don't women don't carry children
anymore [__] Amazon cornered the market
on child birth men don't get women
pregnant now instead your genetic code
is a part of your Amazon citizen ID and
when you want to have a baby you just
open the app design your child it
arrives in nine days also you can decide
the age of your child you can have
whatever age you want for the child you
can have an infant toddler 39-year-old
it's up to you uh and you can get them
in in uh any Yankee Candle scent says
here oh that's pretty Co you can even
get sponsored skins whatever you like
NASCAR Hello Kitty Rick and Morty
whatever you want them to look like and
uh the sponsorship pays for your uh pays
for your children's uh college education
that's cool you you you went to college
I did where'd you go to college USC yeah
that's a good that's a good uh you know
when I went to m D and Grove they uh
they said you had to have a password and
so I went and I just I say the password
I used was Hill Hillbillies Red Mountain
Hill bellies was the one they gave me
because I wanted to stay with all the
all the Texans that makes sense are you
from Texas you're from Texas we're in
Texas you grow up Dallas suburbs yeah
all right let's do the next one okay
this is this is the last one all right
I'm telling you it's bisexual devil
worshippers up there and uh and then
they got and I go by I saw that 45 foot
owl and and you see the owl and you go
okay I know I'm in the right place and
it's you hear Walter kite's voice coming
in over a
loudspeaker Doom and Gloom burn the
Effigy all right this is the last one
all right all right the NBA got rid of
dribbling whoa in 2063 that's big they
got rid of dribbling uh was slowing the
games down so they made it optional so
everyone stopped doing it and nobody
misses it and every once in a while uh
someone will do it just to be funny yeah
I I've been practicing between my legs
move I get in a game or two at the gym
every once in a while nothing serious uh
just pick up with whoever's there but
some of the some of the same guys are
always there the regulars they're gonna
and they're gon to [__] they're going to
[__] their pants when they see me pull
this move out of my back pocket wow yeah
I didn't know exro was played basketball
well and and and and I dribble I still
dribble so in
2063 they had no idea yeah yeah they
they would have uh no idea that that uh
that I'm there and they collect you you
know that Chad they collect you like
trading cards you like trading cards
don't you yeah who's collecting you the
government and they go and they get you
know they get hey I want the I want the
Alex Jones card I want the Tucker
Carlson card The Joe Rogan card probably
and dudy here if they keep doing the
show then they're going to come for the
D dudy Card oh that's pretty interesting
actually yep you know they I I got I I I
got a friend who was is a commercial
airliner and uh he he they told him to
fly you know he flies big guy Elites and
and and they said uh here just fly to
these coordinates he goes there's
nothing there it's just the the ocean
they said fly there and there's a an
island with just billionaires no [__]
five six seven star 10 star and there's
every anything you want big dinners and
uh they got movie stars and stuff and
just bringing in women hunting humans
it's whatever you want so good promise
for a movie
yep thank you moving on Jesus learned a
lot there about the future yeah got to
say oh well getting rid of dribbling is
pretty incredible wouldn't wouldn't have
guessed the NBA would do that in
2063 what the [__] was that about I
don't know dude all right dudy is in an
astonishing partnership with ag1 hi I'm
Chad couchin the current reigning undis
disputed episode champion of dudy and as
the champion I have to make sure that
I'm in top physical condition at all
times and in order to do that I need to
take my supplements until now I've had
to take a bunch of different supplements
but I've discovered ag1 which allows me
to get all my nutritional supplements in
one scoop dropped in a glass of water
every day I drink that down and I feel
great and as you can see I'm in top
physical form he's doing really well I
enjoy it too in the morning I've been uh
I've been making ag1 a part of my my
morning routine for a good while now uh
since they've become a sponsor it is a
science driven formulation of vitamins
probiotics and Whole Food sourced
nutrients you don't have to worry about
all this stuff you just mix it up ag1
you drink it down and it is it is
delicious I like to enjoy it by itself
you could also add it to any protein
shake or your smoothie whatever whatever
you like uh it's it's it's there for you
with all the all of the all of the
ingredients that you need and when I and
if you're watching me do this I'm making
a hand gesture that means this is what
you need you put it in here lulio does
that to me he goes I need something to
drink I go how about some ag1 uh if you
want to take ownership of your health
try ag1 and get a free one-year supply
of vitamin D and five free ag1 travel
packs with your first purchase just for
being a viewer and a listener of the
dudy Pod show go to drink a1.com dudy
that's drink ag1 the number
one.com dud esy check it out I have
created an astonishing partnership with
mind Bloom there's no quick fix for
anxiety and depression remember I said
that and I'm not look I can get into it
we're not Chad this is an ad sure okay
maybe we'll talk about my own Journey
with anxiety and depression during dudy
after dudy please Chad let's just
continue with the ad in my opinion a
Confluence of all things is good you got
talk therapy you can get something uh
prescribed uh by a professional a doctor
and now there's a new tool to improve
your mental health atome ketamine
therapy a lot of people are talking
about it you can look into it M bloom is
the leader in atome ketamine therapy
having safely helped thousands of people
overcome their anxiety and depression in
a study of over 1,200 mind Bloom clients
89% reported improvements in their
anxiety and depression after only two
sessions right now mind Bloom is
offering everybody listening to this
show $100 off your first six session
program when you sign up at mind
bloom.com
dudy and use the promo code dudy take
the first step and break free from your
anxiety and depression with mind Bloom
mind bloom.com dudy and again use that
promo code
dudy speculating about who Taylor Swift
is dating is Big Business right now
she's dating Travis Kel a Mustachio
tight end for the astonishing Kansas
City Chiefs their relationship has
created an explosion in female
viewership of the NFL but still no one
has coined a name for them as a couple
until now I formerly dubb Taylor Swift
and Travis Kel's romantic relationship
Taylor Swift is it's her entire first
and last name with the little is from
Travis's name tacked onto the end like a
barnacle will and Chad what do you think
about # Taylor Swifts did you hear me I
said Taylor Swifts Taylor swiftest
Taylor Swifts Taylor Swifts Taylor
swiftest this is Taylor swiftest
begin okay Taylor Swift is dude Taylor
swiftest brother Taylor Swift is Taylor
Swift tayor Swift Taylor Swift uh so
it's just actually that's a pretty smart
way to do one of those couple celebrity
couple names sure just CU all the the
bank the cash seems to be with Taylor
sft and then you get a little is little
bit of is everyone all that you see on
Tik Tok and Instagram all the things
where the meme has been women going hey
do you know uh who Travis Kel is do you
know who the Kansas City Chiefs are well
Miley Miley Cyrus uh Taylor Swift has
really put them on the map and they're
like no honey this is he was already
there no there's this other guy named
Patrick Malone no but the truth she is
putting them on the map she's more
famous than any of them she's more
famous than the NFL of course well I
don't know about the NFL globally for
sure what Taylor Swift is bigger than
the NFL globally okay well anyway
they're just a couple of sweet kids
having a relationship and I think we
should leave them alone but interesting
dud it's that dudy wants us to talk
about it yeah Taylor Swift is look
Taylor Swift is not
real okay Taylor swiftest I believe this
wholeheartedly now this is a conspiracy
theory call it what you want but Taylor
Swift has been hired by the NFL
because I believe she's going to be this
year's Super Bowl halftime show and so I
think they told her pick somebody
probably somebody from the Chiefs
because it's likely they'll go to the
Super Bowl again start dating them we're
going to build that into a story that's
going to culminate at the Super Bowl
halftime show that's going to be uh
bigger ratings than any Super Bowl in
history because now you're talking
that's exactly what's going to happen
yeah no no Chad that's not what do
you you think you think that um that
this was that they them dating each
other was pre- orchestrated 100% that's
not a chance I don't think somebody like
Taylor Swift uh dates anyone without it
being firmly calculated how will this uh
look how is this going to come out is
this going to help me doing whatever
right now she has the biggest tour in
the world she made a billion dollars on
her tour broke all these [__] records
she has a movie coming out about the
tour she's promoting the [__] out of
everything and when she shows up to
these [__]
games it's the Taylor Swift show they're
they're shooting her in the [__] box
it's major news like dudy said NFL
viewership is going up massively because
of this especially with an audience that
they haven't really ever been able to
capture the women of the United States
of America yeah I don't think I mean
this has to be calculated yeah I don't
know I I I think that look here I'll go
with you on this I think that uh when a
mega celebrity like that uh meets
someone I think they they met quite
organically if I if I and this is [__]
that I don't even know why I know this
stuff yeah but one of the the guys it
was the president of the NFL had a
boardroom meeting with Taylor Swift and
the Kansas City Chiefs and she stood
there and said uh he's okay he's okay
but I'll take him she picked out of a
lineup no Google it but you know there's
a [__] uh someone knew someone and it
was a friend of his friend of hers was
uh friends with someone on the Chiefs
and then they out sounds I do think that
when someone who's a you know big Mega
celebrity maybe they have some of their
people going hey this isn't a good thing
or that's not a good thing you want to
do your background check on someone but
so does anybody dating anywhere and now
of course with the uh with the advantage
of the internet you know people out
there they'll go on a dating app or
something you can learn someone about
the person uh and you can learn things
about the person you go online and and
Google them I think that these are just
two clearly these are just two kids who
they met and they're having a good time
and uh uh I don't think there need I
don't think we need to look more I don't
know who masterminded it might have been
Taylor Swift might have been Taylor
Swift went to the NFL and said look I'm
GNA [__] do you a favor here give me
some [__] chump from whatever team I
don't give a [__] but I want to play the
[__] halftime show and I'll pretend
to date some dude for the whole season
I'll get the [__] numbers up and then
the Super Bowl's going to [__]
explode that's the Super Bowl doesn't no
the Super Bowl doesn't need a a sweet
relationship behind
it it would do some numbers but I don't
think that the I I don't think that it
well okay here I'll I'll tell you this
if we get to the Super Bowl who's we we
the collective Wii we're going to the
Super Bowl no we're not going to the
Super Bowl dudy what do you we get to
the Super Bowl when we when we when
everyone gets to the super bow if
Humanity still exists by next February
that's what you mean no I'm saying when
we get to the Super Bowl okay I was
going to say if we get to the Super Bowl
and okay when we get to the Super Bowl
yeah not only are the Chiefs playing but
Taylor Swift is doing the halftime show
I'm with you I'm 100% with you are you
making that prediction right now yeah
dude you don't think she's doing the
[__] halftime show you think that
Taylor Swift is doing the halftime show
and the Kansas City Chiefs are going to
play against like the Dallas Cowboys the
America's Team team in America's game in
the Super Bowl and it's going to be like
it ain't going to be the Cowboys but
yeah yeah I look I'll also say this
let's say that I'm wrong in this you're
wrong in this I'm not but let's say that
I am at this point the NFL is scrambling
to make sure Taylor Swift is the
halftime show I assume that's booked
before the season maybe it's not maybe
it's booked at some point in the middle
of the season but all this hype around
her and now her attachment to the NFL
nobody else can be the halftime show who
the [__] is going to watch it who gives
a [__] what are they going to do [__]
bring in Bruno Mars or some [__] he's
not dating anybody in the [__] NFL
it's Usher Usher is doing it it says
Usher I just looked it up Usher's
Usher's doing the halftime show well
unfortunately I got some bad news for
you Ur you getting fired they're
bringing Taylor Swift in to [__] do
the halftime show at the very least it's
going to be Taylor Swift on stage with
urer or some [__] like tlor is gonna be
part of it all right you know what I'm
not trying to hedge my bat here I just
you know because I want because you're
wearing that you got the dudy episode
Championship sometimes you say things
and dudy really agrees with them way too
much so I'm just going to say hey yeah
that's good that's good that you said
that and I agree with you I agree thank
you and let's see what happens and I'm
not I'm not doing this as an
experiment thank you moving on [__] it
who gives a [__] anyway you know what I
mean it's who gives a [__] it's just two
kids trying to enjoy their lives will
great Alex Jones today and Chad you're
right on the money as usual with your
theories about Taylor Swift is now let's
take a second to discuss my astonishing
partnership with represent to produce
dudy apparel and accessories you can
find everything at represent.com
store dudy it's the only place in the
known universe to get the new Hoku hogo
kugan shirt which I'm proud to announce
has helped more than 4 million Americans
go to sleep within 36 hours of put
putting it on and good job boner mug
will be playing the main stage at
Coachella this year along with potato
gun the paintballs and Andy Stone this
year's director of Coachella Tom Hayne
couldn't be with us today because he's
shooting a new movie but he sent us a
sneak peek at one of the pivotal scenes
here's a look at potion Pals starring
Tom Hayne and Megan Bryant who's what
Megan I don't know how it happened or
when it happened
exactly but at some point in the last 40
8 hours I fell in love with you hard I
don't care about the money anymore I
just want you I know this seems crazy
but Christina Talisman will you marry me
no you dummy I just told you the only
reason you think you're in love with me
is because your ex-wife hired me to put
a potion in your dudy mug to make you
fall in love with her again long enough
to trick you into signing your computer
company over to her but it's back fired
and you fell in love with me instead I'm
a godamn witch Craig and there's nothing
between you and me we're just potion
Pals will you just give me a chance to
show you that I'm the man you should be
with and how are you going to do that
I'm going to brew a potion just as
strong as yours and I'm going to put it
in your dudy mug and you're going to
fall in love with me just as hard as I
fell in love with you what about your
ex-wife I killed her right before you
got here
holy Fu come on give me some potion just
a drop of potion I just want a little
bit of potion potion potion potion
pretty please potion is as potion
does
[__] holy [__] [__] dude that was
[__] me Megan Megan Bryant oh if
you're enjoying today's episode of dudy
please uh subscribe on YouTube and uh
you know hit all the notifications and
bells and whistles that way you will
know when uh when we got a
new I'm gonna [__] uh when we got a
new episode uh coming up we are at
around 61,000 on YouTube right now
please join us on our march to 100,000
you can do that right now by uh helping
us out and and uh and subscribing to our
YouTube channel uh join us also on
Instagram @ dudy pod show on Instagram
there's all sorts of idiotic [__]
happening there all the time bu of memes
and stuff our wonderful pods paly dudy
are constantly making [__] they're
hanging out in the Discord there's an
invite for that on the link tree uh you
can hit that up we're also on Tik Tok
and the [__] fa uh uh uh Facebook and
I want to thank everyone who tuned in uh
this past Friday to uh waiting to drone
which was our watch along uh on patreon
patreon.com dudy we watched the 2009 CBS
television sitcom pilot that uh this guy
and I wrote and produced for uh for the
television and uh that was insane we
hadn't seen it in years yeah and then we
watched all 30 episodes of copters which
is Chad's uh Opus that he
created for uh his 40th birthday he
played he made 30 you got to just go see
it he made 30 drone
um movies with with his pal from film
school back that you went to film school
with back in the 90s and [__] and uh and
it was that was absolutely uh in insane
so I want to thank everyone who uh came
to check that out on dudy plus and if
you want to support the show keep this
going and uh you would like some more
dudy content please consider subscribing
at the aforen mentioned uh dudy plus
patreon.com dudy gets you everything
that we do on the thing a new episode of
dudy after dudy all the watch alongs and
all that [__] and uh uh share the show
across the internet as I like to say or
follow Chad's light suggestion of
forcing everyone you know to consume the
Pod show now is a good time for me to uh
take a pause so that you can go away and
you can follow the show and you can
thumbs up this episode and you can
subscribe on the podcast platform of
choice and you can follow all our
socials and uh we'll do that right now
we'll take a little break so that you
can do that okay here we
go and welcome back and I would like to
say that if you have a podcast out there
and you would like a guest on that
podcast and you would like that guest to
be me you simply need to send an email
request to book Chad culture atgmailcom
I go through them in the order I get
them there's about a six-month backlog
right now but uh I do three of them
every Saturday from the hours of 10: to
11: a.m. p.m. St in 20 minute chunks and
uh I've been having a blast doing it I
love podcasts as an art form you always
talk about wrestling as an art form
podcasting as an art form to me is maybe
like your wrestling and I love getting
to go into other people's podcasts and
see how they do it this past weekend I I
had some great ones uh and I assume that
I'm going to be tagged in them and I
will share those when they're available
hold on a second dude hold on Chad I
also think podcasts are an art form dude
yeah because you got all sorts of
different kinds of art forms dude you
can paint you can sculpt but you can
also make a show dude out of words you
say brother and you can shoot hold on
dude don't do that well nobody ask for
that brother I also like being on
podcast and I'm going to share this call
to action with everybody if you want to
see us on a podcast simply bombard their
uh social media until they have us on
and that that would be fun that's a good
way to do but do it nicely do it nicely
yeah don't do it the way that we force
uh we ask people or to force others to
consume dudy Clockwork Orange sty it
would be awesome if you had that's great
and then we'll continue keep this thing
going and with all the thumbs up and the
subscribers dudy will understand that
it's my call to action that
has ushered a lot of this on Pardon The
pun urer and uh I'll I'll end up with
that if you want to see that around my
waist I'm going to read some um comments
here these comments are from the
aforementioned watchalong on dudy plus
last uh Friday uh these were on our
patreon page uh this first one is from
Dario Santos that was incredible waiting
to die was great too bad there wasn't
more I loved the owner character lol you
know the owner character they're talking
about the character of Donald played by
BJ BJ Bales yeah a great character one
of the funniest things I think uh we've
ever written uh it was a that that
character was funny f as [__] thanks for
tuning in Dario uh Sam says they should
make more episodes of copters I think
it's one of my favorite things I've ever
watched LOL Sam you have a very specific
sense of humor and who is they me and my
friend Joel I guess yeah you and Joel
should make more and that's a they Pizza
Lover 9000 says bolo young versus karate
bot this is of course referring to the
card if you heard the story you heard
the story I won't get into it but
there's a cardboard standy at the back
of our the set the living Liv room set
where TJ Miller and Josh Lawson live in
the show and it is of Chad and he's
doing this pose and uh it's karate bot
originally we were thinking of having a
bolo young cardboard standup that would
be amazing and this is this is good um
Lauren Ellen conic El conic Lauren El
conic conic says I need more stoned Chad
concert breaks okay allow me to explain
happy to oblige that one I think I could
do that at any time when we do these
watch alongs and these fun things
sometimes on dudy plus and like we did
Friday Chad and I might smoke a little
bit of gabis a little bit of TR
marijuana yeah I got good we got good
and stoned and Chad just started singing
uh he just started he started singing
This is in between the waiting to die
and the 30 episodes of copters I
couldn't open it yeah Chad started
singing I actually enjoyed the [__] out
of it
oh here it is some will never change
there he is that's how I know how stoned
I am when I actually 100% enjoy CH
singing I'm having a good time I know
that's I feel like I got a good audience
when you're [__] high as [__] I'm
like oh [__] it's time to bust out your
true colors true colors are
[Music]
beautiful like a
rainbow not only do I let you s d ding
ding you're conducting me I'm enjoy
D D D D show me a smile
ding realize and I don't even know the
[__] last time I saw you laugh this
world and you've taken all you can then
just call my name and why this song you
know I'll be
there True Colors shining through and I
see your true
colors and that's why I love you so
don't be afraid to let them
show your true girl God your
true are
beautiful like a
rainbow ding ding ding ding ding ding
ding ding oh my gosh thank you can I
tell you something yeah dude I I
[__] you know I would love to see you
too but right now oh yeah you're my
second call that's what I want to see at
the sphere set it
up with this
spear
okay and who can argue with that if you
want more of
that dudy plus patreon.com dudy holy
[__] yeah it was a good time so I've
been doing some thinking and I'm 100%
positive you haven't cracked the
astonishing will sass show yet I'm not
letting this one go guys not until you
nail it so you know the routine keep the
catchphrase lose the rest and give me
some new development on a show for will
to star in called the will sash show pip
pip pip pip pip this is the will sash
show begin
pip we've been trying to develop this
show it's been two three four times now
20 years dude yep and I mean
legitimately the first like I mean the
way we met the way we became friends was
kind of trying to develop a a movie for
you to be in yeah and then we moved on
like waiting to die what we watched on
our patreon was us trying to develop a
show for you to be in I feel like in one
way or another we've been trying to
develop the will sash show our entire
friendship it's a good point so we've
been trying to develop his
show okay well we're going to do it
somay I think we can do it Chad and I
are going to be like we'll we'll [__]
do it and then the show will hit the air
and whatever and then like at the end of
like an incredible successful seven-year
run will be like all right shake hands
don't have to be friends anymore yeah
that's that's how the friendship ends he
did it and it's like no I really want to
be I I love Chad I want to be friends
with Chad nope it's got to be at dudy
steps in your purpose is complete you
must now sever all ties well actually by
that logic not a [__] chance because
we got to be together for another 52
years to do this show we got to do it
dudy said we got to do it for 100 years
okay so advances in medical science how
about a show about advances in medical
science I'm joking of course the only
thing that dudes wants us to keep is the
pip pip pip the Tim Allen pip pip but
you let's say that let's say it's like a
house style it's like a surgery show or
a [__] Grace's Anatomy or something
like that could you get into something
like that I would love to do I've done
some uh I've done a little bit of the
hospital shows tiny tiny bit little bit
I did an episode of of um Grace's
Anatomy once uh no [__] that don't want
to do that yeah what were you in it what
did you do I was I [__] my it's I
don't remember exactly where it starts
but at some point in the episode I work
at the hospital and my legs get crushed
in an elevator and then I fall in love
with uh the nurse the elev that I work
with um and then that's it I don't know
that show's been on for 50 years 257
years they it's insane that's Shonda
Rimes of course nice nice nice people
incredible uh incredible run they've had
the thing I love most about it and this
will tell you something about me
McDreamy they shoot real close oh nice
yeah to where to the house here and uh
and ham fed one studiio convenience yeah
was real close at that studio that's in
the middle of the [__]
BBS Okay so we've got the Tim Allen um
style catchphrase catchphrase pip pip
pip that's what dudy likes we're going
to keep that it's good that dudy likes
that yeah I like it too honestly I do
think it's funny I can see yeah it can
be used like as gibberish just a
nonsense thing or you can use it tonally
to kind of convey anger confusion
frustration happiness like really
anything okay so I think that makes it
good we were just watching us watching
waiting to die kind of yeah um and
um as you said we developed that show
originally if you watch the the patreon
we get into the the the the backstory of
it which was that it was originally a
different show it was developed for me
with me in mind Although our deal was a
writing and a producing deal um but you
know if the network would have me this
is developed for me we then survived the
2008 uh writer strike and they brought
back deals after that and ours was one
of them and uh we continue to develop
and in 2009 we shot a ver a different
show because they said make it two guys
and make it a buddy comedy along the
same lines the same kind of thing they
they liked what we were bringing but
wanted a completely different thing El
came waiting to die uh I did not act in
it they made the age 10 years younger
than me at the time and made it a
younger show but what if we took that
waiting to die sort of framework and
made it about a guy cuz what we really
liked about that was it was two guys in
an apartment together living this sh
well they were kind of they were kind of
slackers but with philosophy okay right
they were they were like we're doing
this on purpose at one point Josh lost
's character tells Josh gad's character
Simon you're married you you you went
and signed that contract and you went
off and Simon's like what you guys are
more married than me uh the only
difference is you know yours uh you know
you guys are together with the joint
bank accounts for whatever UFC and pizza
and [__] what if it's a guy who's
managing an
apartment okay
who what if it's called what if it's
called the manager and it's the manager
the apartment manager and he's a guy who
now with today's um Technologies and
stuff he never leaves his apartment I
like this he's just got screens
surrounding him so he's watching
Everybody in the apartment complex on
closed circuit TV it's kind of creepy
it's like that movie uh sliver the Joe
eser House movie that he did after Basic
Instinct um yeah yeah yeah yeah and yeah
sliver I remember something though in
the pilot has to get him to come out of
his thing so the pandemic has driven
this guy into his kind of self-imposed
Exile
scre all around him all he's doing is
ordering food there's just like empty
[__] boxes and [__] piled up outside
the doorway and Uh something's got to
get him to come out of the hole oh oh oh
oh right on I got an idea what if it's
like the whale okay Brenan Fraser in his
incredible role in the whale I know a
thing about that because it's post whale
protocol right now for me sure I will
not lie to you I've been having some
struggles with the dudy seven-month plan
I've been on it dude I know you have and
I'm proud of you and I want to emulate
it it's you you've been doing you've
been doing really well I'm working out
like a [__] but my food is not
where it should be what where is it it's
in my stomach and it comes out of my
bum pip pip pip umip the guy should just
text message people when they're like I
have a broken [__] light in my
bathroom pip he just text that that
means it'll get done if we if we did
like a thing where this would motivate
me to really lose some weight and get
much better shape yeah my food is well
you know what we're going to talk about
we're going to talk about that in dudy
after dudy we're going to talk about I'm
going to get real and we're going to
talk a little bit about um my where's
your food dude yeah dude where's your
food brother uh we're going to talk a
little bit about the dudy six Monon
seven Monon plan now it's the
seven-month plan that we're about three
months into and how I'm not killing it
like I should even though I'm in the gym
all the [__] time I'm not I'm not
eating properly if you eat late at okay
here here's what we're going to do it's
like it's like the whale okay in the
whale Bren and Fraser dawned a an
incredible amount of prosthetic makeup
and a fat suit and all this [__] we're
going to do the same thing we're going
to have me as I am now um okay maybe in
some sort of flashback or or Flash
Forward a because I'm going to wear a
big fat suit don't make fun don't say
you don't need it I'm on to you you guys
everybody um um I wear the fat suit and
at the same time me will I'm losing
weight like crazy yeah so that we SM we
make the F suit smaller then at a
certain point it's just me as we're
shooting the show and now we're catching
up with me losing weight and it's I
don't know how that ties into a show I
like doing the show in two timelines
like that where the character is
physically drastically different that's
kind of interesting yeah so when is The
Flash back is the the the big fat suit
is
contemporary yeah the big fat in the
future no no no the big fat suit is
where we start let's call the big fat
suit actually will sash show should just
the title underneath should be the big
fat suit okay no it's it's what it is is
the show starts he's like the whale he's
the apartment manager he's texting pip
pip we keep that in for dudy that should
get me a couple of points okay good good
[__] dudy two points for that pip pip I
get a point each pip Point
[Music]
foring um good Pips the show starts with
me and the fat suit the fat suit gets
smaller and smaller we spend the end of
the first season and the beginning of
the second season in my actual skin okay
and then from there I start really
losing weight um because I'm going to
need a [__] show I'm going to need a
television show to motivate me to lose
weight Chad not just things in my life
are taking a I you know I don't know if
we need the the flashbacks though what
if it is about just a guy who's become
this shut in screens all around him
apartment building manager the pandemic
is responsible for it he finds a love
interest and that love interest gets him
back out in the world and to impress her
or him or them this guy has got to
[__]
reemerge come out of the Cocoon find out
who he really is again in the new
world look thank you moving on the
show's going to be fine we're going to
we'll figure out what that show is
whether or not any degree of fatness
that I am but now I want to talk about
the we'll talk about in dudy after dudy
that's guys we did one of these a few
weeks ago and I got incredible data from
your astonishing reactions to my first
standard psychological evaluation so
we're doing it again I've got a few
images here I'm going to flash them up
one by one and you two just say the
first thing that pops into your heads
painless this is a standard
psychological evaluation begin okay so
this is super this is a weird thing that
we did the last time we did this Chad it
was was the uh what was it the Gutenberg
movies yeah it was like three or four
Steve Gutenberg movie posters it was
yeah it was
literally was it uh police academy yeah
Police Academy 2 cocoon and short
circuit short circuit right so it wasn't
necessarily a psychological evaluation
although that's what dud said it wasn't
you know um pictures will pop up first
thing that pops into our head first
thing pops into your head
and and that is the psychological
evaluation of it all oh okay there's the
first thing that pops into your head go
okay so we are looking at a picture
what's the first thing that pops into
your head come on Al hosting the
tonight's show what about for me it's Al
for me Al is the first thing that goes
into mind the picture that we're looking
at we're looking right now at at a
picture of why Al hey the space alien
Alf from the TV show Alf and Alf is is
um yeah sitting at Johnny Carson's desk
from The Tonight Show which that brings
back this episode of Al I think where he
got to host the Tonight Show okay if if
my memory is serving correct amazing
that you remember that yeah did you
watch Al Ed mcmah of course I watched Al
yeah same pip pip and
um Ed McMahon is sitting next to him in
his in his in his usual seat yeah uh and
that's uh that that that I don't get
exactly why what that uh I mean it it
puts me back a little bit I will say
first thing that comes to mind is Al
second thing is kind of like I mean when
was this mid 80s mid to late 80s I was
probably 10ish years old and I was
fascinated with Alf I must say because
there was nothing else like it on
television a it was about an alien B it
was a [__] puppet dude Al was a
[__] puppet that was like Prime Time
sitcom star yeah you just didn't see
[__] like that no it made no sense I
remember yeah I would have been that
show was on in the mid to late 80s yeah
and uh I remember I got into the show it
was it was there was a lot of like um
what was it it was Willie Willie hey
Willie the guy and he would go Dad yeah
the dad go elf I told you not to use the
microwave why did you use the microwave
don't eat the cat Al Al had he was
anti-at he liked to eat cats cuz on his
home World Mel Mac cats were like a
delicacy what a pull okay well there it
is that's that's Alf uh looking it's Alf
and Ed McMahon on the tonight's show
look at McMahon's face yeah I I don't
understand how that is a any sort of
psychological
evaluation uh
okay D's doing something cuz
now now now we're looking at
Alf this is again Alf hosting the
Tonight Show he's sitting at Johnny
Carson's desk he's got the
aforementioned Ed McMahon uh next to him
and uh Rich Little is standing in
between them argue I guess first thing
again is Alf that pops out my head I
mean this is very specific I think it's
from the same episode but Rich Little is
in this one I'm G to ask you a personal
question did he impact you in any way oh
Rich Little of course yeah absolutely
rich little is perhaps rich I think it's
Rich Little and Frank Kendo for me are
the best Impressionists of all time uh
you just got to put them up there and
and then everyone else is underneath uh
Frank and and the uh and Rich Little who
I understand is still doing a show in
Vegas Rich Little is uh re up until
recently holy [__] well maybe we'll
cover it in dudy after dudy I don't know
but this is again we're looking at Al
and Ed McMahon
yeah and um
like iar like was there any I mean I
guess there was like a little bit of a
legacy of Al you had like dinosaurs came
on later on ABC they weren't puppets
exactly but they were like those were
people in suits and then combined with
some animatronic [__] that was a Trope
where it was like you'd have a puppet
thing little yeah a little bit but I
mean you did there were no other stars
of of network TV shows that were [__]
puppets were there in this era no no no
there W there weren't I don't remember
any uh any stars of TV shows that were
pupp well there was Fraggle Rock but
that was all puppets yeah and that was
like more of a kid show but I did watch
the [__] out of that yeah that was a
good show I loved [__] fragar and the
Muppet Show doesn't count because that's
all Muppets and the Sesame Street
doesn't count because that's all Muppets
but um the the the ALF was okay and the
okay here's another
one dude what comes to your mind when
you see this one Chad yeah also now Al
back to because we're now looking at a
picture of uh Al hosting the Tonight
Show sitting at Johnny Carson's desk
with Ed McMahon yeah and now they're
doing the carnack bit where Al has the
carnack the Magnificent outfit on the
cape and that feathered hat uh and uh he
would uh have hold the uh envelopes to
his head and uh he would say the last
envelope and and he would go eing the
last envelope and then Johnny Carson
would look at him with contempt and go
May a yak sit on your face and find a
home in your living room
hey um H when I and thinking about it
now about this time there was another
puppet thing that became like popular
for a second do you remember the Phil
Collins video for or maybe it was
Genesis video for a Land of Confusion
Land of Confusion we've talked about
this that show spitting image yeah was
the name of the show was the British
show yep dude puppet stuff needs to come
back yeah it's not like there is some
Muppet [__] I think still going on but
like it's not like this practical
puppets see AI is taking the place of
Puppets we need more puppets that's what
dudes trying to is that what dudes is
trying to tell us and I'm not trying to
get a point here or two that you're a
puppet interesting interesting stuff
Chad well I think that you know what I
dude God I think that um I wish there
was simpler time dude I think that we
look at ourselves whe you can be a
puppet if you look at yourself as a
puppet let me let me give you an example
do you is this atronics this could be
atronics because I you know as Tronics
go if you're sitting there and you know
you're just you're trying to figure your
your yourself out and you're like me
2008 summary 2008 right when we were
writing the first iteration of waiting
to die God when it was called project
Lonnie I was sitting on the beach in
Venice and just looking out at the water
and
going I'm [__] up my shit's [__] up
I need some Tronics am I a puppet what
am I you know I don't know we and the
way to be you if you look at yourself as
a puppet then you are but I know you
don't consider yourself a puppet under
the under the um the watchful eye of
dudy I'm I'm beyond a puppet I think we
all are I think there is no free will I
think everything we are doing is
predetermined because everything we are
doing implies that there's linear time
which I don't think is real I think this
has all happened before has never
happened will always happen and will
never happen I'm trying to figure out
how that folds into this whatever dudy
work should a pet on waiting to die dude
that's what this is about sh would have
been on the [__] air heartbeat anyway
we should had that was a [__]
pupp thank you moving on that's what the
[__] will sash show needs maybe next
time we do will sash show we got to
[__] throw in a puppet yeah dude
maybe it's a relative of Alf maybe your
character is a [__]
Puppeteer my character is a pu what if
and the The Twist is the puppet's alive
oh how about this we get some we we get
some uh Quanto [__] in there from um
from uh uh Total Recall yeah quat qu
open your mind yeah where where the fat
suit has like different puppets and
different spirits that come out and it's
like Bohemian hold on a second okay it's
like Bohemian Grove yeah and the puppets
come out and then they come right out of
his his fat in his body and they go and
they and they're like I [__]
anyway this concludes the historic 77th
episode of dudy Will and Chad you scored
an 82 bringing your cumulative total to
7,271 you only have
2729 more points to acrew before you
reach your first goal of 10,000 based on
that last conversation I can really tell
you both love Alf so for next week bring
in your favorite piece of Al
paraphernalia thanks to everyone for
joining us this week until next week
call me
dudy uh okay we got to bring
in Alf Alf paraphernalia I do not have
any Alf paraphernalia do you you do you
have any off paraphernalia I got
[Music]
some it's time you know what time it is
yeah dude it's time yeah time is an
illusion yeah and the Macho Man knows
this from his pal CH yeah yeah no don't
do it yeah time doesn't exist he doing D
doesn't exist it's Macho Man Randy SW
Niger yeah everything that happens now
has happened before and has never
happened yeah and that just that's a
constipated yeah
constipated M vent
me you don't just [__] repeat what I
say and then go here it is okay oh I'm G
from U the The
Bachelor dude amazing [__] you that's
great [__] I'd love to hear you do more
of that [__] you dude hey [__] you bro
how about that yeah
unbelievable welcome to dudy after dudy
the flagship weekly show of dudy plus if
you'd like to join us visit
patreon.com dudy if I could have a
moment to be honest here it feels like
this week was close I'm going to have to
do some more calculations to determine
the episode champ I'm excited to get
started have fun without me this is dudy
after dudy begin absolutely just like d
said it's it's getting close I'm feeling
the heat it's getting a little close and
and Chad you know we're we're in dudy
after dudy now it's my favorite part of
the show we're just going to chill we're
going to hang out crack wise it's two
dudes [__] around
but you know last week at the end of the
the dudy after dudy when dudy divies up
the points and named you again the dudy
episode
Champion D said that I was being a
little manipulative during the show you
called it D said it hey Will I know what
you're doing uh and I was sensitive to
that this week as you as you noticed and
I sort of kept track of my head of where
our pal D may be wanting to give me some
points and some rewards and and I think
that on today's dudy after dudy it will
end in a nice return and I mean that I'm
coming for
that tell a friend then
R if you like d what you
do please tell a friend then r a
review if you like d here what you do
please tell friend then